[Musique]
olalala
s'épancher c'est vraiment envie c'était
de ma boîte préféré bizemont servait
pour tâcher mais présents
françois qu'est-ce que je les
tiens
casimir
jamais vu ainsi que lui arrive t il mais
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas osé lui
parler j'ai préféré venir te prévenir tu
as très bien sages les je vais aller lui
parler à toit ils n'auraient sans doute
pas voulu se confier tu as raison mais
tu crois qu'il va te parler à toi bien
sûr d'ailleurs tu vois
quasiment
slc mois comment était aujourd'hui des
émirats voici vraiment pas la question
la plus intelligente à me poser tu vois
pas que je suis désespéré excuse moi qui
dis mais je croyais agir avec tact du
talent tu mais je ne suis plus un bébé
j'ai pas besoin de tarte avec talk avec
tact cela veut dire avec finesse
habilité
et bien c'est complètement raté
d'accord et compris l'expliquent mois au
moins pourquoi tu es aussi triste non
mais quel humour je t'ai déjà dit non
alors tu ne veux rien et c'est justement
mais je n'y comprends rien mais je
parlerai h vie voilà c'est tout et
pourquoi j'ai les seulement parce que je
suis triste et que j'ai besoin d'être
consolé mais quand je lis me console
beaucoup mieux que toi
c'est l'eau
[Musique]
gelée va voir ce qui ne va pas avec
casimir
moi je vais terminer tranquillement
mourir mais françois ne te vexe pas
lille si malheureux il ne sait pas ce
qu'il dit ou ce qu'il veut tu as raison
console de bien mais ne lui pose pas de
question précise tout de suite je vais
essayer
alors casimir tu es vraiment si
malheureux que ça oui mon oncle
archibald m'a demandé de lui renvoyer la
jolie boîte à avec un séreux rouge
c'était ma boîte préférées là il me
l'avait pas prêter il me l'avait donné
tu t'es peut-être trompé casimir le
cadeau c'était le petit chat qui était
dans la boîte la boîte ne servant qu'à
transporter ça fait rien c'est quand
même injuste
or mon pouf casimir tu l'as lu a renvoyé
la boîte mais oui tout de suite j'avais
cru obligé parce que tu sais mon oncle
archibald et des très sévères et
coléreux
j'ai tout entendu casimir et je suis
vraiment navré pour toi veux tu que nous
fassions veux tu que nous jouions au jeu
des mimes vont changer les idées non il
y avait été faire une course en sac non
j'ai pas envie in dos aux non je suis
trop aux désespérés or mon pauvre
casimir bonjour tout le monde abou
chauffeur on vous savez casimir est très
triste parce que son oncle archi
casimir
tiens regardez c'est moi pamecas et
rouge
attention quasi mais attention pour
surtemps marchi bad a mis un nouveau
cadeau de da un nouvel animal a
je crois bien que toutes les
explications sont sur cette cassette
dans cette enveloppe qui forgèrent
khadir je marchais le plus vite plus
haut plus loin je les avais cherché pour
lecteurs de 17,6 coup mais alors vous
vous appelez les enfants entendues
un enfant qui nait vital est engagé
si vous aimez c'est la peur je te
prendre la boîte non non non non ce
monsieur je m'amuse beaucoup et je ferai
comme la dernière fois je vais rester
pour tenir la boîte si vous ne voyez pas
d'inconvénient france - pas du tout
facteur robots en très bon alors on
commence j'arrive je suis très cool a en
effet annoncé
roger casimir c'est moi comme tu m'avais
envoyé une très gentille lettre pour me
remercier du petit chat je vous ai
décidé de faire un nouveau cadeau
tu connais le principe du jeu à chaque
numéro de la série
correspond la présentation d'un des dix
balles c'est ça il faudrait trouver le
bon numéro pour ouvrir la boîte faites
bien attention tu dors à le croire
ça ne va pas être facile hein
heureusement tous les enfants sont là
araud il vous chez vous vous aider
casimiro cia
allons-y
je suis très grand et jeu court très
vite je porte de très belles plumes je
suis gourmande mais heureusement je
l'estomac très solide je vise en afrique
sur la serrure rouge g le numéro
quel est cet animal devin
quoi non nous ne touche en quatre lots
et neutre ' c'est une autre
je le trouve très beau je suis certain
le véritable roi de la basse cour je
suis orgueilleux et batailleur mais mon
rôle le plus important est de servir de
réveil matin sur la serrure rouge g le
numéro deux
vient donner le monde surtout le facteur
aussi à tous ces facteurs de répondre
bon à part ça ne colle pas moi que
deviner que c'était un contre un le
réveil la tonne s'est mariée ce rallye
saint gély s'il te plaît à une autre je
suis un mammifère mais je vis dans la
mer on dit que je suis le plus
intelligent des animaux j'aime beaucoup
amusé et surtout avec les hommes je sais
faire pleins d'acrobaties sur la serrure
rouge g le numéro 3
quel rôle de
aucune idée de qui a dit ça à tout faire
certains comme dans la chanson à quoi
reconnait pourquoi pas reconnu qu'ils
sont de grands mammifères
à nos tenues mais parce que j'ai deux
longues oreilles j'aime beaucoup les
carottes je suis très gentil mais aussi
très heureux car je n'ai rien voulu
défendre sur la chirurgie
si le numéro quatre du
[Applaudissements]
conflit l'explication pour que nos
petits amis puissent aider casimiro 6-1
alors laisser finir l'explication
même si votre maison elle me plaît
je ne comprends pas pourquoi c'est
toujours du mal de moi on me traite de
pavant
anne et demi plus me plains chinois je
suis beaucoup plus joli que les autres
et que les courbes ou sur la serrure
rouge g le numéro c'est bien dit annie
rooney
qu'est ce qui peut bien sûr là parce que
la people a dit écoute bras souvent leur
voyage aurait dû y penser oui tout ce
qui brille elle le prend l emporter dans
son immense à une telle annonce est
apaisé les prêts à
je vis en amérique du nord je suis
beaucoup plus gros que ma cousine la
vache qui vit en europe j'ai toujours la
tête baissée avec du poil brun et frisés
dessus avant nous vivions très nombreux
avec des indiens et depuis l'arrivée des
hommes blancs mais pareil ont presque
tous été massacrés
sur l'acer rouge g le numéro 6 à nouveau
et
c'est un bilan à dix ans bravo quasi
meilleur je crois que nous avons tout
écouter ouais tu as une idée moi j'ai
trouvé dans la boîte c'est un bison
disons vous êtes d'accord les enfants
non pourquoi est ce qu'elle est trop
petit et oui bien sûr beaucoup l'eau
tombée autre idée si c'est pas un bison
c'est une autre lui chat et l'autruche
c'est ça à votre avis un petit vous avez
grandeur de la boîte qu'est-ce qui reste
alors quels sont les animaux qui
pourraient rentrer dans cette boîte pas
non plus comme
un oiseau là puis il ya eu la cote à la
partie que je dis c'est la table ils
attendent quoi parce que y'a des herbes
qui dépasse
moi je choisis aussi le latin toujours à
boire mois les 110 sur maintenant je
pense que vous avez raison pour bons
numéros 4 numéros car je met en jeu mais
à la
fin on va voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nine pics et bien il a un peu peur après
son grand voyage